Denise and Brian this is the spot in
this neighborhood where Lenny was killed
you can see behind me a huge Memorial
still growing with a lot of people out
here paying their respects tonight now
as police continue to search for who did
this his family sat down with me tonight
to share more on who he was
a father overwhelmed by the loss of his
son
and his entire family
shocked by the sudden death of Lenny
castillon his cousin Mario sharing
everything he'll miss about him and
Lenny was a jokester he always laughed
the 27 year old was found dead in the
street in this neighborhood near
Charleston and Jones police say he was
shot early Sunday morning
this Memorial now continues to grow when
it's a crime like this where like nobody
knows who did this nobody knows why as
officers still search for whoever did
this Mario says his family is desperate
to find answers the whole violence thing
I mean it's just it's just one thing
that you know hatred brings hatred you
know this it's never going to end and
until someone steps up and he's the
better man and they hope by speaking out
they can get one step closer to Justice
he just wishes that whoever did this
gets caught for the man they say always
brought light into their lives as a
father friend brother and son he was
just you know always fun every time
every time he hung out with them you
always had a good time while also
Shining Light on the violence they say
has changed their world forever as a
community we should be better
now the family has started a GoFundMe to
help with funeral expenses now if you
have any information as to who may have
done this call police or Crime Stoppers
where of course you can remain anonymous
reporting live tonight Sasha Loftus 8
News Now